in this video we're going to talk about
cellular respiration which sounds like a
very fancy thing but it's really just
about the biochemical processes that can
take things that we find in food and
convert it into forms of energy that we
can use to do things like run and
maintain our body temperature and
maintain body homeostasis
so to get into the chemistry of cellular
respiration and this really is an
overview video we will start with the
chemical equation for respiration
and what it's all about is a series of
steps that when you look at them in
aggregate you're starting with the
glucose right over here using oxygen and
that's why we have to breathe really
hard in order to do our cellular
respiration and it's going to yield some
carbon dioxide which we also need to
breathe hard to exhale some water and
some energy now that energy is in the
form of heat which can help us maintain
our body temperature especially if it's
cold outside but also atp
now you might be wondering what is atp
and to help us answer that question i
will show you a picture of atp and i
will also show you a picture of glucose
or visualization of it now you don't
have to memorize what these structures
are but what's really going on here is
that glucose as you are able to shape it
into other things as you're able to
break the bonds in glucose and having
its constituents form bonds with other
things that has a net release of energy
and that energy can be used to stake
what's known as adp that has two
phosphate groups and add a third
phosphate group onto it right over here
now you might say why is that useful why
is that a more readily usable form of
energy well as you go forward in your
biological journey or your understanding
of biology you'll see that atp molecules
like this by losing that phosphate and
allowing that phosphate to bond to other
things can actually release energy and
can fuel muscles can fuel other
biological processes now to understand
the steps of it we will start in the
cytosol of a cell where a process known
as glycolysis takes place and glycolysis
literally means the breaking of glucose
so let me write it down glycolysis
and what it does is it breaks each
glucose molecule into two molecules
known as pyruvate now just that process
alone and we'll go into much more depth
in other videos does start to produce
some atps and also helps produce some
molecules known as nadh and i know this
is all sounding very complex but you
will have a molecule known as nad plus
if you want to know what it looks like
it looks like this once again don't get
too bogged down in the details it is
worth noting nad stands for nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide and we also notice
that atp stands for adenosine
triphosphate and so you have these very
similar molecular components that are
showing up in different places in
biology and you might also recognize
that adenosine is involved in the
formation of dna as well so once again
these molecules are adapted and reused
all over the place but going back to our
journey of cellular respiration an nad
plus molecule if you were to add to that
two hydrogen protons and this is the
important part two electrons
it will be reduced to
nadh
and remember reduction is the gaining of
electrons which is happening right over
here and the reason why these two
electrons are really interesting is in
nadh they're at a fairly high energy
state and as we'll see as they're able
to go to other molecules and go to lower
and lower energy states they're able to
do useful things that can eventually end
up in the production of atp it's
essentially a transfer of energy so
glycolysis is directly producing some
atps and it's also reducing nad in this
way to produce nadh for the next stage
we have to go into the mitochondria
which is often known as the powerhouse
of the cell where now our pyruvate will
enter into the mitochondrial matrix
right over here and that's where
the citric acid cycle occurs
and the citric acid cycle is going to
use a derivative of the pyruvate which
we got from glycolysis you don't have to
know all the details it's called acetyl
coa but that's going to go through a
series of transformations and the reason
why it's called a cycle there are some
molecules that react with the acetyl-coa
and then through a series of
transformations get back to where they
started and the reason why it's called
the citric acid cycles one of those
intermediaries is citrate but this
process once again produces more atps
directly but it also produces more nadhs
and it also is able to do something
similar to another molecule and once
again i'm not going to go into all of
the details but we're able to go from
another molecule known as flavin adenine
dinucleotide fad
plus two hydrogen protons plus two
electrons to get to fadh2
which once again is an interesting
molecule because it has these electrons
in a higher energy level which through a
series of molecular processes which
you'll go into much detail in future
courses on you are able to do useful
work you are able to transfer energy
so once you have a few atps and a bunch
of nadhs and fadhs you then go into
something known as the electron
transport chain and this is essentially
where those electrons go from a high
energy state and they get transferred
from one molecule to another actually
along this membrane right over here and
as they do the proteins that they are
interacting with they're able to use
that energy in order to pump hydrogen
protons into this intermembrane space of
the mitochondria and then that
concentration gradient of hydrogen
protons it's released through another
enzyme which is actually able to produce
the actual atp
so i know that is a lot to process but
this is meant to be just an overview i
know you might have a lot of questions
as i did the first time that i learned
this but the important thing to realize
that glucose does store energy but we
don't use it directly we have to go
through cellular respiration to convert
that glucose into atps which is more
readily used by cells now the various
steps are also going to produce heat as
they release energy which could also be
useful for the cell
now one final point you might say
glucose well that's only one form of
food you showed a picture of bread
initially well carbohydrates are made up
of chains of simple sugars like glucose
and if we're thinking about things like
protein or fats which you could also use
for energy those are going to be adapted
and enter at different phases of
cellular respiration but at some point
you're going to have a very similar
process so i lied i actually have one
last last point
we talked a lot about glucose as it
enters into glycolysis and then the
pyruvate enters into the mitochondria
but what about the oxygen where is that
involvement as an input
well the oxygen is the eventual electron
acceptor at the end of the electron
transport chain and not only is it
accepting electrons it's accepting
hydrogen protons so the oxygen is an
input into the electron transport chain
and then once it gets those electrons
and those hydrogen protons well you can
imagine what the output is you add some
oxygen to some hydrogen protons and
electrons you're going to get
water you're going to get this output
right over here
and what about the carbon dioxide well
the carbon dioxide is going to be an
output of the citric acid cycle